special thanks to bespoke post for
sponsoring this video
at the beginning of december 2021 i set
out on a mission to review all of the
live-action spider-man feature films in
detail i kicked things off with toby's
trilogy and then earlier this month i
explored the often criticized but seldom
appreciated andrew garfield films both
of these experiences were wonderful as
they offered me the chances to revisit
memories from my early adult life in the
case of andrew garfield and my childhood
in the case of tobey maguire however
today we are exploring something
fundamentally different on so many
levels and i think far more challenging
from a reviewer's perspective and that
is tom holland's contribution to the
live-action spider-man mythos these are
not films i grew up with and as such i
predict won't be able to depend on the
same nostalgic strings that the toby
films did or perhaps the same
coming-of-age reactions that garfield's
offered me those two franchises i saw
during formative parts of my life and
tom holland is the first spider-man
actor cast that's actually younger than
me and no i'm not salty about that you
are furthermore these are films that
take a fundamentally and enormously
different creative approach to both
depicting the character physically and
narratively unlike the previous films
which were in and of themselves
contained within their own respective
movie universes with spider-man as their
main character in three of the six films
spider-man appears in the marvel
cinematic universe he is not the main
character not even close how will this
impact my analysis
only time will tell but these have been
the films that i've been most excited to
explore and revisit so let's dive right
into my review of every tom holland mcu
appearance as he dons the mask as the
definitive spider-man for a brand new
generation of fans
i have no idea how to write this review
these aren't words i would normally
utter to myself let alone write on a
script and voice over my microphone to
thousands of people but it's true the
prior films felt much more
self-contained by their very nature and
as such could be judged on the merits of
each film with perhaps minor references
to the first film in their respective
sequels you see the mcu spider-man
requires those that have watched them to
have seen specific parts of other marvel
films in order to get the full and
complete experience this is partially
what makes the mcu so darn fun and
immersive but as a reviewer it makes
conveying my emotions concerning
specific narrative decisions much more
dependent on study and well having seen
all the films that built up to that
point that happened to span across 20
plus films peter parker isn't introduced
in his own film in the mcu but instead
he is introduced in captain america's
civil war which into and of itself is a
captain america film the third captain
america film which deals largely with a
moral dilemma between the likes of
captain america and iron man
respectively and iron man oh geez okay i
forgot to talk about iron man the entire
character of peter parker in this series
is intrinsically tied on some
fundamental level for the majority of
these films to this specific character
who by the way plays a leading role in
five mcu films if we are excluding any
film he takes part in with spider-man so
i guess what i'm trying to say is here
in order to fully appreciate and come to
grips with the character of spider-man
as he exists in the mcu to be certain i
understood what they were going for in
these films i needed to see every other
film in the mcu and well i did that over
the last decade i've watched every film
and over the last year i've watched all
of them twice and in addition to that
for the purposes of this video i went
ahead and watched all of the mcu
spider-man flicks three times each with
his appearances in civil war infinity
war and endgame countless more times so
in essence i am all spider-man out so
without further ado or preamble let's
start from the very beginning iron man
okay just kidding we're starting with
the beginning of phase three in the mcu
with captain america civil war this is
our introduction to tom holland's
spider-man and to tell you the truth
back in 2016 just two years after andrew
garfield's amazing spider-man 2 the
sentiment growing in support leading up
to this unveiling was that of well i
don't want to say indifference people
were very much excited to see him
involved in the mcu but there was
certainly a feeling that we had already
seen the spider-man origin so many times
and we've gotten so many different
spider-man so close together that it
seemed like there was too short of a
span of time between garfield and tom to
really justify another reboot of the
character and i was one of those people
cautiously excited to see one of my
favorite characters among the ranks of
marvel's dynasty built over the last
decade but i gotta say disney and marvel
they really knew what they were doing
with this character from the very
beginning
do i need to do that i know we're on
different teams i just don't want to be
disrespectful to you
everyone seems to have a different
opinion on which actor is their favorite
playing the wall crawler but regardless
of what you think i don't believe
there's any denying the unique set of
skills and attributes tom brings to the
table for this specific role in an
interview with david elson the main
stuntman behind andrew garfield's and
tom holland spider-man he went into
detail and opened up about what his
experiences were like working on both
incarnations of the character citing the
mark webb garfield films as much more
grounded with a much more serious take
on the character with a specific focus
on appearing more spider-like in its
movements whereas on john watson's set
there was a clear and obvious leaning
into the more humorous and human aspects
of the character with his more awkward
mannerisms highlighted to draw attention
to the boy beneath the mask rather than
the alter ego that is spider-man
blending the two of them together to
create something that i think makes for
the most interesting approach to the
character at least from a directorial
point of view furthermore and perhaps
most interestingly at numerous points in
this interview david ellison refers to
tom as the real-life spider-man showing
his admiration for him not just as an
actor but as a performer and stuntman in
his own right
what's it like working with him he seems
like spider-man for lack of a better way
of putting it he seems like peter parker
in real life he is and and so much of
that is to tom's credit like
thomas is an amazing human being he's
one of my favorite people one of my
favorite actors i've ever worked with
he's just such a nice guy he's insanely
talented so like we also had like three
months of prep i think on that show and
he would come in and train with us and
he's he's so damn talented like we'd put
him in the wires and he'd be epic in the
wires him and i would like play uh
add-on or not even add them we would
stick it we play stick it so like i
would do a flip and if i stuck it
without moving then he'd have to stick
it before he could move on to the next
level
and there's like we kept doing that and
man he was just sitting there right with
me wow just keeping up i mean he's so
talented and
he comes from a dancing background he's
an insanely talented dancer and just
he is spider-man like what he said is is
absolutely what it is he is spider-man
just
the way he is his his just phenomenal
like abilities and just everything he is
spiderman and keeping all of that in
mind when i took the time to really sit
down and admire his performance as both
peter parker and spider-man in captain
america civil war i really appreciated
the quiet sincerity and clumsiness he
brought to the role of peter parker as
he struggles to confide in tony stark
whose dynamic with peter by the way
would be enough to easily carry a scene
on its own but there's so much more to
it there's a childlike optimism with
this version of the character from the
outset which immediately caught my
attention after coming from toby and
andrews films which concerned themselves
largely with a tragic origin story from
the outset to define the character and
that's what makes this peter different
from any other that we've seen for this
appearance and indeed these early films
he's not necessarily defined by tragedy
but instead by his admiration for his
idols and this is where a prior
understanding of these films comes in
handy and serves to enhance the
experience upon first meeting peter
parker tony hasn't traveled to queens to
outright recruit him right away instead
this is more akin to an interview than
an offer in many respects with him
testing peter's wit his honesty and most
importantly his motivations where his
actions come from and in perhaps the
best moment of the scene we get this
look from tony once peter answers that
very question in this moment he not only
understands peter but realizes that this
kid is in many respects on a similar
journey to him
peter's remark concerning him feeling
responsible for bad things happening if
he can stop them holy and totally rings
true to tony's arc as a character not
only during this film but within his
entire run in the mcu from the beginning
it's the cornerstone of his character
and in establishing that commonality and
bond between these two characters the
more screen time they share the more we
believe in their relationship and indeed
peter as a worthy spider-man this film
was very much trialled by fire for the
young character allowing him to bounce
off the likes of tony stark steve rogers
and many others introducing him to this
franchise with a bang without detracting
from the overall story of this film that
centers around cap and iron man
specifically from the little of him that
i did see in this film with him being a
dumpster diver unassuming nerdy
interested in trying to do the right
thing all the while being star struck by
tony it served up a performance that
convinced me upon first watching this
back in 2016 that tom holland really and
truly does make for a terrific
spider-man and indeed a compelling peter
parker
feel like i could be doing more you know
i'm just curious when the next real
mission is going to be
2017 spider-man homecoming there's
something i need to confess before i
dive into my review of this film and
that's that in 2017 i wasn't a big fan
of john watts as a director he had
directed movies in the past like cop car
which is a good crime drama and 2014's
clown which is a not so good horror film
that is to say neither convinced me that
he had what it took in his wheelhouse to
create not just a convincing
coming-of-age superhero film but a great
spider-man movie that was until the
press junk in promoting spider-man
homecoming where he was interviewed and
asked about the film on a technical
level and i adored it at the beginning
of the movie peter loves being
spider-man but he doesn't love being
peter parker you know peter parker sort
of represents everything that he was
which to him is just a weird
outsidery sciency nerd
and now he has this whole new future
life ahead of him being a superhero and
having met tony stark and
you know
thinking that he beat up captain america
and all that you know that's all he's
already moved on
but what he hasn't done is uh
sort of come to terms with who peter
parker is
and everything that sort of happened to
him in the past i think that's going to
be the journey is him realizing that you
can't move ahead to be spider-man until
you've really figured out who you are as
as peter parker there were obvious
decisions made during the production of
this film to help it stand out and feel
distinct from the other spider-man
feature films of the past there's no
traditional origin story in this film
iron man plays a pivotal role and
there's absolutely zero web swinging in
new york city
however what this film does have is a
tremendous amount of heart and
dedication to telling an honest and
uplifting coming-of-age tale the likes
of which to this day still has elements
that bring a tear to my eye every single
time i watch it and that's how i know
i'm dealing with not just a tremendous
actor that understands and cares for the
character of spider-man but a dedicated
director with a compelling vision for
what he wants to try and capture right
off the bat according to tom holland
himself director john watts before he
even gave tom the script for this film
assigned him a list of john hughes
movies to watch in order to get his mind
straight for what he wanted to attempt
with homecoming and indeed this trilogy
of films and when i consider his
approach through this lens i can really
see what they were going for a young but
eager protagonist yearning to prove
himself having to contend with questions
of identity and maturity all the while
being faced with obstacles of troubling
circumstances both from the past and
present that in the end help to form the
basis of who he is and ultimately who he
will become dealing not with
straightforward and unrealistic tales of
black and white but instead ugly shades
of grey and so while this film does bask
in the gif that is childhood and
adolescence it absolutely makes a point
of contending with the nuances and
troubles that come with that transition
to adulthood michael keaton's depiction
of the vulture adrian tombs has been
widely touted and praised for his
spectacular performance and i am 100 in
that camp too and similar to other films
featuring the wall crawler over the
years peter's conflict in this film has
an interesting relationship with his
main antagonist like many wonderful
villains across pop culture tombs or the
vulture as he's often referred to is a
sympathetic antagonist to peter's
protagonist octavius norman marco dr
connors and dylan are all to varying
degrees sympathetic villains with
misfortune being a contributing factor
to their respective rises as villains
however i think of all of these
individuals the most human and
understandable individual explored in
this rogues gallery of villains is
through tombs in spider-man homecoming
initially hired to clear up the debris
following the attack of new york in the
avengers film after spending his life
savings to facilitate this possibly
lucrative endeavor he's undercut by
stark industries middle management
leading him to a life of crime stealing
this tech initially in order to provide
for his family however once he gets a
taste of what's inside this metaphorical
cookie jar he sees it as a means of
creating wealth for himself to hit back
at those that have treated him so
harshly business is good
spider-man or should i say peter parker
on the other hand isn't living so
positively this film starts his journey
from the perfect place reliving his
proudest moments from civil war in a
brilliantly modern but character-rich
sort of way we get voice over talking
heads and the look on his face once tony
says that he can keep the suit says it
all he feels like this makes him an
official hero now it's a wonderful
performance from tom holland who
throughout this opening sequence brings
with him a childlike enthusiasm and
innocent determination running in direct
contrast to tomb's jaded and proud
mentality helping old ladies stopping
bike thieves and other such minor
incidents after all we've seen him do in
civil war alongside iron man this places
us in the same mindset as peter in this
film desperate to see him do more but
this movie unlike the andrew garfield
and certainly the tobey maguire films
isn't hell-bent on stripping this kid of
his innocence with reckless abandon
instead the entire point of this film is
to explore his more innocent and younger
years and it's in exploring that aspect
of childhood that i think this film
series does better than the andrew
garfield films did in that respect it
creates a community while not as
explicitly camp and melodramatic as the
raimi trilogy it does go to great effort
to elevate the supporting cast through
the likes of ant-may mj ned and a
variety of other kids in his school that
paint this world with a touch more color
than it otherwise would have had without
and it's in these more light-hearted and
fun high school moments we can feel the
inspirations of the breakfast club and
ferris bueller's day off reinforce this
coming-of-age atmosphere but most
importantly sorry peter i guess we're
still losers peter parker feels like a
loser when we first discovered this
young teen in captain america's civil
war tony sort of plucks him out of his
regular life without giving us as an
audience a chance to really see who he
was or what his social standings were
but in this film we can see plain as day
why peter holds those 15 minutes of fame
when he rubs shoulders with the world's
greatest heroes so near and dear to him
because they were the single best
moments of his life moments where he
didn't feel like a loser where he didn't
feel like people were laughing at him
moments where he didn't feel like peter
parker but instead
a superhero and it's in pursuit of both
tony and happy's attention and approval
that he consistently runs into trouble
with tombs who once again although
indirectly is put through some grief
courtesy of tony stark and his new
spider suit which brings me to the
action there are a large number of
action scenes in this film however my
favorite is this
[Music]
god i love this movie for including
scenes like this one in previous films
with toby and andrew honing their powers
we caught glimpses and snapshots of them
becoming the prolific web slingers they
eventually became hurting themselves
thousands of feet into the air with the
greatest of ease we never really got to
see that awkward middle phase in any
meaningful capacity outside of a scene
or two but right here it's the star of
the show and it serves the scene and
films spectacularly showing how brave
peter can be by blindly running to his
friend's rescue no matter how dangerous
it is but also in addition to that it
reinforces how limited his experiences
have been and how far he still has to go
until he's fully ready to take on the
big bad world i also love the
choreography in this section where he
flips and glides over the helicopter
smashes through the ballistic glass
saves everyone and shares what is
perhaps an awkward but funny moment with
liz courtesy of his in-suit ai karen
however no matter what when he's trying
to be what he thinks tony is looking for
he ends up falling further and further
away from that end goal
so
you got detention but this heroic image
or bravado he seeks to demonstrate are
exactly the opposite of what tony saw in
him day one in that very first scene
they shared in queens he saw that tony
was impressed by his youtube videos and
that he said that he was in dire need of
a major upgrade top to bottom however we
know as an audience from looking at that
scene that the moment he decided to
recruit peter wasn't because of all of
those extraneous feats or powers but
rather his answer to that one question
he asked him what's his motivation and
in that moment of honesty peter parker
not spider-man peter parker earned tony
stark's respect and attention in this
film peter's pursuit of this image he's
trying to uphold leads him to hack his
suit put all of his friends in danger
and puts his own life at risk on a
number of occasions resulting in him
getting more in the way than helping the
situation until it reaches a boiling
point where all his lies and pretense
catches up with him and he's confronted
by the person he was looking to regain
the attention of
tony there's a brilliant quote in this
scene in fact there's a couple one of
which i'm pretty sure many of you will
remember if you're nothing without this
suit then you shouldn't have it it's a
brilliant line that speaks to the
philosophical battle taking place in
peter's head but the quote i love the
most and i think the quote that
transcends this film and speaks to the
entire trilogy is this one shortly
before that i just i just wanted to be
like you and i wanted you to be better
there are turning points like this in
pretty much every western film and most
definitely coming-of-age stories where
they're confronted by their flaws and
have to make a choice in this instance
peter feels as though the choice has
been taken away from him tony has taken
his suit and in peter's own words at
least this is all i have i'm nothing
without this suit and so due to his own
mental block right now he feels as
though tony has made his decision for
him resulting in a return to the status
quo for the young teen he goes back to
hanging out with friends participating
in classes and well really doing what he
should have been doing before focusing
on his future and helping people when
and where he can which leads him right
to where he wants to be in a position
where he can ask liz to the homecoming
dance and surprisingly to peter she says
yes suddenly things are starting to look
up he feels a tremendous amount of
responsibility lifted from his shoulders
his life seems to be going in a positive
direction and now he's going to pick up
the girl of his dreams for homecoming
he must be peter when i first saw this
in theaters i was genuinely shocked this
might be up there with some of the
better mcu surprises too not just for
its clear shock value but also for what
it offers the story the scene where
tombs drives his daughter and peter to
the homecoming dance all the while we
watch on as he creeps closer and closer
to figuring out who peter parker really
is is shot perfectly and incredibly
tense there's not much in the way of
commentary that i can point out that
others already haven't pointed out but
what i do want to point out concerning
this scene happens on a narrative level
once discovered and confronted by tombs
peter is presented with a dilemma inside
is everything he as peter parker has
wanted friends a relationship some fun
for a change validation that he isn't a
loser a chance to experience things like
a regular teen should
but peter parker because of who he is
was only ever going to make one decision
look when you can do the things that i
can
but you don't
and then the bad things happen
they happen because of you
this has always been who peter parker
really is it's precisely who tony stark
saw that day and it's the person who
peter's been unwilling to accept
throughout this story but he's always
been there amidst all of the naive
decisions peter makes during this film
that lands both he and others into
trouble littered across those are
moments where the real peter shines
through where he does the right thing
irrespective of the consequences the
other night you told that dude if you're
gonna shoot somebody shoot me
it's pretty ballsy following this he
confronts tombs once again thinking that
he will be enough however he still
hasn't accepted who he truly is he's
consistently tried to pretend to be
something he's not throughout this movie
and right here as he's being crushed
beneath tremendously heavy debris he
crumbles crying screaming for help this
is a state and level of vulnerability
we've never seen peter parker endure
before however it's through this trial
by fire that he looks down to the mask
resting beneath him in a puddle the
words of mr stark echoing in his ear
suddenly he knows that he has it within
him whether he is gadgets or not whether
he has the support of anyone or not on
his own he is enough he is a hero only
in accepting this is peter able to find
the courage he needs to defeat tombs the
battle takes peter to heights he's never
seen before forces him into
circumstances he's never dreamt of but
he finds his way never compromising who
he was in the process culminating in a
moment at the end of the film where he
stands in direct contrast to where he
was at the start with peter parker
having started to come to grips with
what it takes to be a hero denying tony
stark's offer to join the avengers in
their compound overall i love this film
but as i pointed out in the beginning of
this review this is but a stepping stone
on the long and arduous journey thomas
peter parker takes across the marvel's
cinematic universe next up infinity war
and end game
yeah but first a quick word from our
sponsor subscription boxes are all the
rage these days and it's hard to find
ones that are truly worth it ones that
go beyond gimmicks and actually provide
you with useful products that you will
really use thankfully bespoke post is
one such service that delivers great
stuff and at a fantastic price point for
me their awesome cooking boxes are where
they really shine the over easy box for
example comes with a high quality cast
iron pan which is already a steel and
yet there's also a heat resistant pot
holder pancake mix maple syrup and a
bloody mary mix they often talk about
how every box is around 70 dollars worth
of stuff in it but only costs 45 and
that certainly rings true to my
experience the feast box has a high
quality carving knife which is crazy
when you think about how valuable good
knives really are likewise the smoke box
is insane value if you're looking to up
your flavor intensity in the kitchen
this bad boy comes with a full smoking
kit and wood chips all for just 45
dollars it's such a versatile service
and it's all picked for you based on
your own preferences when you sign up so
if cooking's not your thing maybe you'll
love their outdoorsy stuff or fantastic
knives you get to choose ahead of time
so you can swap if need be or even skip
a month for no charge if nothing tickles
your fancy you only pay for what you
want if this all sounds great to you
then click the link in the description
or go to bespokepost.com
not mark 20 and use coupon code not mark
20 for 20 off your first box
it's difficult to know where to begin or
even stop with my analysis of spider-man
in this finale to the infinity saga
combined altogether these are the two
films that make up my favorite part of
the mcu by virtue of how they solved so
many narrative obstacles and delivered
upon so many plot threads in what i
consider to be an immensely satisfying
fashion however for the purposes of this
review i can't afford to get too carried
away with iron man's involvement as i
have two other films with which i want
to talk about his impact on this
character and the mcu at large and so
just because this will be the last time
we'll see iron man in this video it
certainly won't be the last time his
impact or presence will be felt or
referenced not by a long shot so if
there's something you feel like is
important to the spider-man character in
these films that i don't touch on
understand that odds are i will address
them in the far for home section right
after this
hey man i think more than anything else
what spider-man and indeed peter parker
adds to this film is a grounded sense of
naive but determined altruism a desire
to help in whatever way he can and to
show he's willing to stand up for
something that he knows is greater than
he could possibly imagine which is a
really long-winded way of saying he's a
nice and brave boy the various action
scenes early on come equipped with a
quippy and well choreographed nature to
them very reminiscent of civil war with
spidey going back and forth with iron
man to achieve a desired outcome however
unlike civil war we are now dealing with
a more mature and fully realized version
of spider-man the kid that was once
easily benched in civil war following
the airport battle now has a clear
enough sense of self to follow what he
believes to be is the right thing to do
when his mentor tells him no even if
that means chasing after his robotic
sensei and in doing so puts the fear of
god into him to what extent should
spider-man be an extension of iron man
at this point in his tenure i asked this
question because at this point in time
following end game after having been
introduced through iron man to the mcu
and having leaned heavily on iron man in
his opening feature film despite this
being a truly breathtaking and
emotionally rich performance from tom
holland as he gets snapped away and
returns in time to aid in the final
battle against thanos before his mentor
passes on it's very much the case that
in this film spider-man is less of a
main character servicing himself but
more so a key supporting character to
aid tony in reaching his end point in
this end game this fact coupled with his
prior dependence on the character in
addition to his new iron spider look
gave fuel to a growing sentiment online
is this spider-man or is this iron man
junior and in many ways i can understand
that point of view however there is
something i would like to say in
response to that not necessarily from a
narrative point of view right away i'll
address that later on in this video but
more so for now a financial and business
sense no matter how we may feel as a
collective fandom surrounding these
films this franchise or this character
spider-man as he currently stands in
2022 as of making this video is not a
marvel studios property but instead
owned by sony this has been the case
since before the toby films were even
conceived of in 1999 and due to this
fact despite spider-man being a
massively important character to marvel
even today even as far back as infinity
war and in-game i could not see a world
where marvel with all the success that
they are seeing with their new
characters would thrust all of the
weight and circumstance surrounding
their biggest hitter tony stark to a
property they ultimately had no control
over doing so would simply ruin whatever
leverage they would have during
negotiation processes with that said
when all the dust had settled following
the events of endgame having traveled to
space fought against the most imposing
force we've collectively ever seen in
these films and after becoming an
official avenger with all the trauma
that comes with that responsibility
peter parker emerges out the other end
alive but at what cost
we won
this is dark
spider-man far from home
i'm not exactly sure if this is a
popular or unpopular opinion but either
way i'm thrilled i finally have a chance
to speak openly and freely about this
film because upon first watching this
movie i didn't like it all that much
however upon my second and third
viewings it managed to become one of my
favorite marvel movies and i'd go as far
as to say that i think this is in every
sense of the word not only a brilliant
marvel film but a terrific spider-man
story however if there's one thing that
watching reviews of this film across
both youtube and rotten tomatoes has
shown me it's that what one person might
define as distinctly spider-man another
might not recognize as such spider-man
and the coming-of-age journey he
represents in pop culture is a broad one
a very broad one and i think that's for
the best if spider-man could be narrowly
defined then by definition that very
audience that loves him too would
represent only a narrow cross-section of
the population but instead almost
everyone loves or can at least on some
level connect to the messages of this
character and that's one of the reasons
why i love him and this film because
despite there being a multitude of
forces at play here some that drive the
plot in a massive way not limited to the
now laid tony stark this film still
manages to cover what i believe to be
one of the most cathartic and powerful
spider-man lessons i've enjoyed in a
long time both in a fictional narrative
sense and in a very real somewhat meta
sense also i've reserved a lot of time
in this review where possible to discuss
tom holland as an actor and this is
because i honestly find him fascinating
as a spider-man actor no of course i'm
not a male escort then you're spider-man
and this is because i honestly find him
fascinating as a spider-man whether or
not you're in the camp of toby andrew or
ortom as your favorite something is very
unique concerning tom's circumstances in
this role and i noticed this a few years
ago while tom and director john watts
sat down for an interview promoting
spider-man homecoming in it it was
brought to tom's attention just how
close his experience experiences with
the role also mirrored the life of the
character he was portraying which upon
hearing made me recall when longtime
spider-man stuntmen david elson referred
to tom time and again as the real-life
spider-man unlike tubby mcguire and
andrew garfield who were both in their
late 20s when assuming their respective
roles as the wall crawler tom holland
was a largely unknown teenage kid he had
made a splash in musicals like billy
elliot and some minor tv stuff but
outside of that no one really knew who
he was i remember opening my pc back in
2015 and seeing this kid's face as one
of the people rumored to pick up the
mantle in the mcu as spider-man and it
was only when i looked into him and what
he had to offer that i took notice in
addition to his dancing and rudimentary
gymnastics background he was much much
younger than any other spider-man that
came before him and as the years
trickled on by and i eventually stumbled
across that interview for homecoming i
realized that tom holland the actor's
journey mirrors peter parker's in many
respects think about it a relatively
unknown kid gets scouted by the biggest
name in town he gets taken under the
wing of their main guy and wants to do
everything he can to not let him down by
doing the best job he can eventually he
might feel as though the mantle is being
passed down to him and now for the first
time this young man needs to figure out
how to man this ship all by himself
without the help of his mentor's guiding
influence all the while his large shadow
looms overhead as the reminder of what
he has to live up to and this is all to
say that tom has as of writing this
video beat in six mainline mcu
blockbusters and had his own trilogy of
films by the age of 25 still by the way
younger than toby and andrew both were
when they first put on the suit just
something i thought was interesting to
keep in mind but for now on to the
review of far from home
does anyone have any neighborhood
questions what is it like to take over
from tony stark there's some big shoes
to fill
this scene right here summarizes the
conflict in this film in a nutshell if
homecoming was all about peter exploring
and accepting the strengths he has as
peter parker in other words trying to
eliminate any illusion he might have
about himself then far from home is a
story detailing how peter has to learn
to see his mentor for who he truly was
not as a deity without fault but as a
gifted man that struggled and failed
just as much or more than any other
person in peter's life in other words he
must learn to not hold himself to some
impossibly high standard and to stop
doubting himself when he inevitably
fails in living up to that impossibly
high standard to stop looking at tony
through rose tinted glasses but to quite
literally look through the eyes of the
man tony believes he could be that's
what far from home is ultimately about
at the end of the day and once again how
disney and marvel have elected to
leverage tony for the purposes of this
film is sensational and a perfect
epilogue to the infinity saga which
concludes in this film in terms of
pacing this is up there with the
absolute best
the selling point of this movie is
spider-man in europe and boy does it
deliver on that front in keeping with
the mcu's dedication to help this
spider-man feel distinct from the older
incarnations they are keeping him as far
away as possible from the skyscrapers of
new york city and instead have him
occupying hostels in venice navigating
festivals in prague and drone striking
on alpine motorways and that's just the
first third of the film i think my
favorite part of this movie at least in
the first half before the story finally
shows its hand is how much john hughes's
influence can be felt within john
hughes's films there's always a
concerted effort to bring to light the
individual humanity in as many
characters as possible whether they be
high school kids or a middle-aged
businessman from chicago trying to get
home in time for the holidays and in far
from home you can really feel that
driving the dialogue and indeed the
narrative in some places ned and betty's
relationship is hilarious and cute
brad's motivation to stop peter from
connecting with mj on this trip is
filled with hijinks and mysterio's
ultimate motivation once it's revealed
is understandable it's not right but we
can empathize with the position he was
put in by tony stark which further
speaks to his flaws as a human being
that peter needs to learn to accept
quentin beck is in this film a villain
specifically because of tony he's proof
that tony isn't perfect and speaking of
mysterio can we just take a second to
appreciate how brilliant jake i had to
google the spelling of his name
gyllenhaal was in this film there's a
bit of a mystery surrounding mysterio
you don't say towards the beginning of
this film however due to my being a fan
of the old spider-man games and 90s
cartoon i knew full well who mysterio
was which did take the fun out of what
ultimately was a great reveal in the bar
with mysterio to get peter's edith
glasses from him however i did get to
experience the genuine surprise on my
wife's face when i showed her that scene
so there's that prior to the reveal
quentin beck or mysterio played on
peter's biggest insecurity his belief
that he can live up to tony's legacy and
in playing up to that he becomes exactly
what peter thinks he needs a mentor
figure to hand over all of this
responsibility too and not for no reason
but because for the first time since
becoming a superhero he's happy to just
be peter parker he has other priorities
you look really pretty
therefore i have value no
no that's not i'm messing with you
you look pretty too
nowadays there seems to be a ton of love
out there for zendaya as an act and in
light of this i find myself in the
position to say i too love zendaya now
brave as a statement that is i do have
an explanation for my take and
furthermore i wasn't always in favor of
her version of mj in this series for the
longest time i was lukewarm on it and
this change of mind came about courtesy
of a specific creator here on youtube
that i highly encourage anyone who's
interested in learning more about
spider-man to check out and his name is
implicitly pretentious in one of his
many videos deconstructing the topic he
drew specific attention to something i
found deeply interesting and eye-opening
whenever i watch a film or write a
review i'm always looking for another
way to examine something that might
offer with it a renewed perspective or a
deeper understanding of the approach a
filmmaker might take when making a movie
and in one of his videos he discusses
the broad topic of comic to film
adaptation with focus on the character
mary jane watson specifically through a
modern lens in my review for mark webbs
the amazing spider-man i drew specific
attention to webb's incarnation or
approach to adapting the character of
peter parker for a modern era as
mentioned in that video toby moore
closely resembles what peter parker
would wear aesthetically in the 60s but
the attitude and get up andrew carried
through his performance ran closer to
authentic for what peter parker might be
if he was written for the year 2012.
this is in effect why i love zendaya's
performance as michelle jones or mj you
might have noticed that in my review for
sam remy's trilogy i praise kirsten
dunst's performance and her dynamic with
toby however i did not praise it for its
comic accuracy like i did garfield's
performance in the comics mary jane is
quite progressive for the 1960s when she
was introduced to the world and while
everything from the hair to the clothes
kirsten wore in the rainy films felt
true to the character in a classical
sense it failed to capture the spirit of
the character which was her progressive
and exciting spirit in fact that
incarnation of the character felt sort
of i don't know conventional or sort of
safe when i frame it that way and so
enter mj from the mcu understanding what
i do now concerning mary jane from the
original comics mj in the mcu is exactly
what i would envision a modern take
channeling the spirit of that character
might sound and act like this is all to
say i love her performance in this and
while i don't feel as connected or
invested in her relationship with peter
as i did with gwen stacey and emma stone
i can absolutely respect what she brings
to this variation of the character and
i'm majorly impressed
quentin beck or mysterio is not only a
visually exciting choice to attack peter
parker within this film with but is also
i think by design a brilliant metaphor
to represent the issues peter parker has
to overcome in this story i mentioned at
the beginning of this section that
homecoming was the story of peter coming
to terms with his strength and worth as
an individual peter parker independent
of all the bells and whistles tony's
mentorship afforded him that he has
value that he is a hero in that same
breath far from home explores the
natural continuation or evolution on
that idea in peter now having found a
new lease on life as a civilian who
wants to try and embrace and enjoy a
normal life for a change he's confronted
time and again with either massive
depictions of iron man at school or in
the real world and when he dons the mask
as spider-man people clamber to ask him
if he's the next in line to lead the
avengers and to him he thinks this is
ridiculous he doesn't believe he can
because to him he cannot possibly live
up to what iron man represented to him
and so in this film he struggles to
overcome that image or illusion of tony
stark in his mind in order to see the
reality of the situation and who better
to face peter parker and his grappling
with reality than the master of
illusions mysterio and the visuals
surrounding these illusions are utterly
spectacular with a capital s watching
these illusion sequences in the theater
left my jaw firmly planted on the floor
particularly when iron man came crawling
out of the ground as a zombie as an
illusion literally haunting peter
eventually and thankfully this leads to
a beautiful coming together with happy
where he confesses to peter that tony
like peter always second guessed himself
but the suaven cam front was exactly
that a front and upon receiving this
news and getting a new lease on life the
look happy gives to peter as he's
working away on the plan for the final
battle warms my heart and brings a tear
to my eye every single time and speaking
of that final battle and confrontation
between peter and mysterio it's still up
there as one of my favorite spider-man
moments out of all the films i've spoken
about across all three videos i've made
on spider-man the choreography is
incredible the visuals are appropriately
massive and it has a swerve at the end i
honestly didn't see coming but was
totally perfect for someone like beck to
try and pull off however my favorite
aspect of this big finish was the
philosophy behind its design this is a
movie about seeing people for who they
truly are whether they be villains
allies mentors or indeed yourself to not
allow yourself to be consumed by those
illusions and so the dependence on
peter's spider sense during this film
was incredibly refreshing and frankly
inspired with it at the beginning of the
film acting up according to ant-may
representing his inability to see
through the illusion of tony stark's
shadow in other words the incorporation
of the spider sense i think acts as a
beautiful metaphor illustrating that in
order to take control of this situation
and to save the day peter can't rely on
a catch net iron man can't save him
another hero isn't going to come out of
the woodwork he must be willing to look
deep within himself to gain clarity to
trust his intuition to trust his senses
to trust himself and to accept that tony
chose him for a reason it's brilliant
it's beautiful it's poetic it's so damn
spider-man and it's a perfect segue into
spider-man no way home
spider-man no way home spider-man no way
home is special and as you can see for
the purposes of this review i've elected
to change the format up a little bit for
this section and i highly encourage
anyone who hasn't yet seen no way home
for themselves in theaters to do so if
they have the means because i sincerely
believe that this is the best
live-action spider-man film made in over
15 years and since spider-man 2 back in
2004 no way home is the first spider
flick i've seen in theaters more than
once in fact i went to go see it three
times i would have gone a fourth time
but arlen went a little crazy with
kovitt over december and well my ticket
got refunded this is all to say that i
believe spider-man no way home is a
terrific film that made me tear up made
me laugh and kept me at the edge of my
seat from start to finish and contained
within it are elements that make not
just for a terrific film but the perfect
ending to this trilogy of videos i've
written over the last month in
celebration of the live-action
spider-man i've grown up with so what
are we waiting for let's dive right in
as this film continues from the
conclusion of far from home without
missing a beat you could put these two
films back to back and they'd flow
perfectly furthermore the pacing in this
film was a little lopsided with the
first half feeling distinctly slower
than the second i will say that the
first half isn't slowed by any
conventional means either the first 10
minutes deals with a great deal
including the fallout of peter's
identity being revealed to matt freaking
murdock's introduction to the mcu films
to happy and may's relationship troubles
to what this film's main driving force
will be peter's desire to help his
friends better their circumstances at
any cost unlike any of the other films
in the mcu home trilogy this film also
feels distinct due to its lack of focus
or involvement of iron man in any
capacity the first had him directly
involved the second it was indirectly
and now this his presence can't be felt
outside of some extraneous tech here and
there which further adds to this feeling
of isolation and dwindling options for
peter to utilize in order to better his
friends chances when applying for
college and that's one thing this film
does a great job with right off the bat
this concept may or may not have worked
in the comics however when adapted
correctly into the modern day the court
of public opinion as murdoch puts it is
in full effect people swarm mj and peter
initially a woman shouts out that peter
hit her and as they jump to safety a man
is seen leaping after them to compound
this protests are held outside of
peter's school bricks are thrown through
his window and literally everyone in his
life starts to treat him either as a god
or a murderous criminal and this is the
strongest aspect of the film's first
half it really made me feel for peter
and ultimately understand where his
thought process was when he was reaching
out to stephen strange
this is where the story really starts to
take shape and again with a time check
we're only 20 minutes into the feature
i've seen a lot of critics claim that
the pacing in this first half of the
film is slow but in reality i think it's
quite fast and satisfying and my only
explanation for people feeling
differently is that they compare it to
what comes in the second half or their
anticipation of what comes in the second
half should i say and i think that's
largely it because let's face it it was
the worst kept secret in hollywood in
late 2021 one strangest spell flops and
accidentally releases a ton of villains
from past spider-man stories the fun
really starts to ramp up with references
and interesting interactions as the
order of the day dr octopus vs peter on
the bridge was choreographed
spectacularly well with some really
interesting ideas at play concerning his
iron spider suit fittingly the method
peter ends up using to overcome octavius
in this instance is a difference that he
uniquely possesses when compared to any
other spider-man also with his suit
moving to protect his chest it
additionally to looking awesome and
being an interesting way to reveal
peter's identity to otto it also plays
into the theme of peter consistently
shedding more and more of tony's
materials working towards that
independent outcome that the film
concludes with on the topic of villains
however let's call a spade a spade
because not all villains are created
equal in this flick flint marco and dr
connors are both in this film acting at
the sandman and lizard respectively
however their involvement particularly
the lizards is quite removed when we
compare it to more involved characters
like electro or dr octopus and speaking
of electro in this film i found him so
much more entertaining than he was in
the amazing spider-man 2. now that's not
to say that this version of him would
have worked better for that movie i
honestly would have a difficult time
trying to convince myself of that
however his suave and much more witty
persona is perfectly fitting for so many
interactions we get to see in this
feature particularly in happy's
apartment where we get a chance to
explore so many interactions we thought
we'd never see
and on the point of villains i had to
say something outright and without an
ounce of hyperbola i'm not sure if
anyone else out there will agree with me
on this but william defoe's performance
of green goblin and norman osborne in no
way home might be better than his
performance in the first spider-man
flick with toby and let me be completely
clear here i loved both but i thought he
had so much more to work with in this
film and was afforded the chance to go
even further with his insanity too like
that seat in the apartment where peter's
senses are triggered and he dukes it out
with the goblin that scene is
oh chef's kiss brilliant i mean when he
punches him time and again and the
goblin just laughs in his face man
that's a moment that still gives me
chills and not even to make mention of
the ending or
okay
breath let's talk about what norman
offers this story because this movie
simply wouldn't land or work as well
without him out of all the villains used
in this film none is more important or
contributes more to peter's journey than
norman one of the best choices in this
film comes by way of peter's motivation
to save all of these villains it's such
a perfectly character-driven choice that
speaks to his aunt may's philosophy
which
comes to a screaming and haunting
conclusion in this film's turning point
yielding the single most important quote
to live by in peter's life that with
great power
must also come great responsibility and
this took me off guard both
intellectually and emotionally going off
of peter's very first conversation with
tony in his bedroom back in civil war i
always assumed in the six months leading
up to that conversation his uncle ben
scenario had already yielded that
outcome for him as he loosely speaks of
that same responsibility in that film to
tony it's what convinces him to recruit
the kid in the first place but similar
to the garfield film it never sat right
with me that that quote wasn't there but
thankfully now we can say that it is and
when that moment hit like the train that
it was it made me realize perhaps the
most important aspect of this story this
isn't just the culmination of a trilogy
of spider-man films but the culmination
of peter parker's origin in the mcu
with his final trial coming in the shape
of villains from the past and present
offering him a moral dilemma one that he
needs to answer with mercy which after
what norman did to his aunt may seems
like an almost impossibility which
brings me to everyone's favorite part of
this film the bringing together of toby
andrew and tom's respective spider-man
to one location and to share a heart
to heart one of my biggest worries going
into this film was over how they might
mishandle or fail to deliver upon what
was a fascinating angle to tackle the
darkest moment in this young character's
life but this delivers in more ways than
i could have hoped to describe and to
that point this is one of the darkest
marvel movies point blank dealing with
themes of death anger revenge
responsibility and isolation with this
scene where toby and andrew support tom
being perhaps the best scene in the film
and let me tell you andrew freaking
garfield almost steals the damn movie
tom holland and william defoe share what
are perhaps career defining performances
however after seeing this film three
times in theaters one of the most
standout aspects of the movie still
remains andrew's tortured portrayal of a
defeated peter parker following
the events of the amazing spider-man 2
struggling and desperately clawing to
what semblance of hope he has left in
him trying to hold on to gwen's wish for
him to never lose hope he doesn't have a
ton of lines in this film but this
spectacular actor maximizes his minutes
in this movie let me tell you leaving me
honestly in a situation where i feel
like begging sony for the amazing
spider-man 3 to give this poor character
some closure and speaking of other
spider-man watching toby bounce back and
forth with andrew was special and to
tell you the truth made me feel like a
teenager again and similar to the
villains what this film does extremely
well is allow time for these characters
to hang out and just shoot the breeze
and to tell you the truth i'm counting
down the seconds to when this becomes
available on disney plus or blu-ray
because i want to watch it again which
brings me to the ending and this was and
let me tell you in all honesty
perhaps my favorite ending to any
spider-man film ever
now that might be subject to change over
the course of the next year as this film
settles deep into my subconscious but
there's just so much to love about this
part of the movie getting to see toby
suit up again andrew redeeming himself
by saving mj and electro wishing
spider-man was black all really cool
nods to the past and future of this
franchise but perhaps more than anything
else what i love about this section is
the final battle between goblin and
spider-man with subtle touches like
peter going for a punch and us as an
audience really feeling that impact
telling us that not only is peter
serious in this instance but unlike
earlier in the film where these pulled
punches made goblin's face light up with
laughter now they make him laugh for a
whole other reason they're an indication
that goblin is getting to him and that
peter is playing right into his hands
but toby
stops him
the anger in tom's face crumbles to
sorrow it's a brilliant scene that
climaxes with peter making the right
decision in the end
saving norman
over the years one of the main critiques
of this spider-man that i've noticed has
been his dependence on the abilities and
accessories of other people
predominantly iron man so much so that
it's led to numerous people over the
internet labelled tom's portrayal as
iron boy or some variation thereof and
while i understand that sentiment i
can't help but praise marvel's
dedication to this idea it offered tom a
tremendous way into the mcu with one of
the most popular characters it offered
him a unique trauma that he alone had to
deal with and perhaps my favorite aspect
of his alignment with iron man is the
visual progression he demonstrates
throughout the films as he becomes less
and less dependent on the stark tech
until finally he reaches the natural end
point for spider-man a down on his luck
teen living in new york city alone
wearing a costume he made living with
all the decisions and mistakes he's made
in solitude it's a haunting but perfect
way to end this trilogy with a kid that
was once desperate for recognition in
homecoming after going through
tremendous loss and growth developed
into the adult we see today totally
willing to forgo any and all recognition
quite literally for the sake and
well-being of his family his friends and
the world and looking back through this
trilogy and his involvement in the mcu i
can't say i would change anything it
truly was in every sense of the word a
celebration and a love letter to the
spectacular and the amazing spider-man
growing up spider-man helped me to
become a better person and the only way
peter parker spider-man and indeed
marvel can consistently achieve that
valuable effect it has on people is by
allowing their characters to grow change
and adapt to the social ecosystems of
the era they find themselves in and in
that respect i think tom holland's
version of that character is as
important iconic and as valuable to the
mainstream idea of spider-man as toby
and andrew's contributions however if
marvel and disney maintain their
trajectory with this character in tom
holland spider-man it is my belief that
he will be someday the definitive
spider-man not just for the new
generation but perhaps the old one too
furthermore this won't be my last
spider-man video alright i had plans to
review into the spiderverse as part of
this by december but i think i'm going
to wait for its sequel to release so i
can give my thoughts on both of them
together because honestly that first
film on its own deserves to be part of a
big video like these ones did so if you
want to see that video or more videos
like this be sure to like and subscribe
it doesn't cost you anything and it
really makes my day with that said i
hope you enjoyed this spidey sember and
i thank you so much for watching
[Music]
watch as we all fly away